guillaume huit ans kevin neuf ans on les
appelle les microbes de la compétition
parce qu'ils sont jeunes mais cette
première course ils la prennent très au
sérieux étape obligatoire le repérage de
la piste et avec papa de préférence
l'importance est passée par là peut-être
non tu sors du jeu illuminées d'accord
sera trop vite
des passes à un braquage la piste est un
peu dur est plutôt rapide pour de si
jeunes surfers
ajoutez à cela la nécessité de slalomer
verdict plaisir elles figurent deux
cents jeunes de 7 à 14 ans se sont donné
rendez-vous à villard de lans pour
partager leur passion du surf
une passion qui peut faire mordre la
neige assez souvent et peut faire mal
aux smartphones on retrouve de la
luxation d'épaulé luxation du coude
on trouve des fractures du poignet des
fractures de bras et d'avant-bras donc
essentiellement les membres supérieurs
des gamins et son petit donc ça semblera
été plus loin ils sont très souples donc
c'est un art qui se passe mal loin de
toutes ces préoccupations kevin et
guyane sont dans le portillon de départ
ils ont une place à défendre
sur la plus longtemps oui le chronomètre
importe prenant m aujourd'hui c'était la
fête et comme on dit
l'important est de eur